طبعا العراق للاسف وفق المركز العراقي
استراتيجي لحقوق الانسان يسجل تسعه اشهر
19 الف حاله طلاق في الربع الاول من العام
وهذا ما يعني انه يسجل تسع حالات طلاق
خلال الساعه الواحده بغداد تتصدر
المحافظات من حيث
حصيله حالات الطلاق وتليها البصره طبعا
هذه الاعداد فقط
لخمسه عشر محافظه ما عدا محافظات اقليم
كردستان
وطبعا المركز الاستراتيجي لحقوق الانسان
يحذر من ارتفاع هذه الحالات التي قد تقود
الى التفكك الاسري ويقول ان اسبابها هي
العنف الاسري والفقراء الزواج القاصرات
وارتفاع نسبه البطاله هي ظاهره مقلقه
بالفعل زينب طبعا ولكن عندنا موضوع ثاني
ايضا للاسف ليس اخبار جيده كارثه بتهدد
العراق ونقص غير مسبوق بخزينه
بخزينه المائي منذ 100 عام فشو هي تفاصيل
الكبيره ايضا
نعم هذا ما اعلنت عنه وزاره الموارد
المائيه خلال المؤتمر الدولي للمياه
الثالثه الذي يقيم قبل ايام في بغداد
وذكرت ان الواقع المناخي او التغير
المناخي اصبح واقعا المفروض على العراق
اضافه الى السياسه احاديه الجانب لدول
المنبع التي باتت تؤثر على منسوب مياه
نهرينجله والفرات طبعا هذا النقص اصبح
واضحا من خلال النقص الذي نشاهده نشهده
اليوم في عدد
المساحات الزراعيه التي تناقصت الى النصف
في العراق بعد ان كانت 32 مليون دونم
اصبحت 18 مليون دونا فقط وايضا اثر على
الحيوانات التي تقع الى الجانب المجاور من
الانهر مثل مثلا عدد البحيرات الاسماك
بالعراق التي تناقصت من
6500 بحيره متر مربع كيلو متر مربع الى
500 كم مربع نعم يا زينب يعطيك العافيه
ويوم الاحد احنا راح نتريق عراقي عليك
بالعافيه اذا تاكلين
اليومر احنا راح تاكلين شو اسمه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات